hello there I'm Karen warden with don't
purge the radio show or outside the
studio of the beautiful la talk radio
com i'm here with filmmaker craig mulet
hello there how's it going good yeah
thanks for having me on the show today I
I brought you a DVD of my documentary
about my mom hey uh hot here called the
closer she gets wow it's Mother's Day so
all the more reasons thank you very much
you're very touching now your crowd
funding on kickstarter yep four straight
on till morning and i understand the fun
by date is june eighteenth yep jun 18
third 1159 p okay all right no pressure
um once the campaign is done whatever
the outcome how do you plan to continue
with your marketing social media
whatever yeah well that's definitely one
of the things that we're trying to do
right now and what we started to do
before is it is to build a buzz about
the movie hopefully build some fan base
get people excited about seeing its
using facebook and twitter and blogs and
Elvis you know all the different ways of
online because especially with
independent film it's a good way to if
you don't have a bunch of people who
want to see the movie then who's going
to go see it like how are they going to
find it in this huge crowd of you know
independent movies that exists so we're
hoping to get a good bunch of fans you
know as many as we can gather and keep
them involved to blog updates and as we
shoot the movie like you know here's a
clip from the movie you know here's an
interview with the lead actress or actor
that kind of stuff to just keep people
excited about the movie and what's
coming with it so that when the time
comes if the movies done they'll be like
yes we have to see this movie and and
that will hopefully help us to get a
distribution deal or even if we do it
ourselves to be like yes we need to show
it in Iowa City Iowa because you know we
want to see this movie this is exciting
to us so we're definitely gonna be using
all that stuff as much as we can and you
know Brian tourism is going to be errors
and design it's the main guy like behind
that side of it because he knows the
internet like a master here so hopefully
he's a Jedi Master of the internet okay
and so he's helping to make sure that
that all all happens hopefully in a good
way we've had other filmmakers on who
said that it's great to build that
audience and that's all wonderful and
makes you feel good but then there's
that pressure to keep that audience
happy and sustain that audience what are
your thoughts on that well that's a good
question you know in the sustaining the
audience is definitely a pressures I you
know I feel like it was I gotta put up a
blog entry I gotta you know post on
Facebook or whatever and I'm not good i
just i mean honestly for me like i want
to be making a movie like I get that
this is part of making a movie as is
raising money and and all that stuff and
getting a scene but like I love the
making the movie part so much that
sometimes I might not focus on this as
much as I showed maybe about keeping
people happy as far as keeping people
happy I mean honestly you have to make
the movie for yourself I mean I really
think that it's like and it sounds sort
of selfish but that's not really the
idea the idea is if you're trying to
please everybody you're going to place
nobody and it's true and it's a sec I
really feel like if you focus on telling
the best story you can and a story that
will you know thrill you and excite you
and it comes from the heart then that
will translate to being something that
other people are interested in excited
about saying whereas if you're like wait
now all this person says they don't want
to see this happen and this person says
we need more of this and then the next
thing you know your movie turns into
kind of every huge giant blockbuster
that's not good that comes out every
summer as opposed
the ones that actually sell are good
you